alors on vient au vélo on l'a vu la
semaine dernière beaucoup de nouveautés
technologiques pour améliorer les vélos
romuald bonne ans était déjà venu nous
en parler notamment pour les recherches
de position sur le vélo mais aussi dans
l'aérodynamisme et dans les roues il ya
beaucoup de travail et une entreprise
française leader du marché mondial c'est
un française située à loriol dans la
drôme frédéric renoux et olivier robert
ont rendu visite à cette entreprise
ça ne se voit pas vraiment mais ici on
fabrique un élément indispensable au
vélo ça c'est du monde enfin presque car
tout reste à faire
au commencement cette simple bande tissé
de fils de carbone
à l'arrivée une roue du vélo high tech
en europe
une seule entreprise fabrique ses roues
en carbone avant d'équiper la plupart
des équipes du tour elle laisse dans cet
atelier qu'au début on a eu des
discussions au carbone que j'ai déposée
dans avec le secteur en mousse et puis
ces dernières étapes donc à la fin jour
une jante en gamme
cette gente est ensuite chauffé elle
ressort du moule avec sa forme
définitive on fabrique ici 8000 routes
par an un artisanat de haute technologie
au moment de concevoir une roue le
maître mot c'est la performance
une performance mesurée sur un curieux
engin qui reproduit le déplacement réel
de la roue verdict de la machine les
meilleurs roues sont les goûts carbone
profilées parce qu'elles sont très
légères très rigide et aérodynamique
trois qualités indispensables pour
comprendre un peu de physique vos coups
de pédales produisent de l'énergie qui
arrive au niveau de la roue la haine se
transforme en vitesse mais une partie de
cette énergie est perdu un gaspillage
d'autant plus grand que la roue et
lourdes souple et pénètre mal dans l'air
le couplé gagnant c'est donc carbone
plus aérodynamisme
on peut par exemple à 40 km heure sur
une route bien profilée gagné 10 % de la
puissance à fournir pour maintenir cette
vitesse de 40 km heure par rapport à une
roue traditionnel résultats des
recherches cette roue carbone profit des
profilés mais équipé de rayons car
légèreté et aérodynamisme sont surtout
importants au niveau de la jante des
rayons moins de carbone conséquence et
romain schaer devienne accessible à tous
ce verdict de georges prix athlètes
amateurs en souffrance et des
professionnels donc on a besoin d'un
matériel assez assez performant et puis
après c'est tous des sensations là
certains plaisirs confort
donc on apprécie après et puis la
douleur oloumi complètement fini douleur
bonjour vitesse carbone ou pas la roue
aucun inventeur n'a trouvé mieux pour
aller vite à vélo